[Applaudissements]
sauver mais il veut pourront pas il ne
pourront rien sur la troisième fois
[Musique]
c'est ma déjà troisième année ici et
vraiment je suis impressionné par les
villes
moi j'aime bien la nature et autour de
Tours même dans son centre ville il y a
des parcs aussi mais nous on adore
balader sur les lacs il y a plusieurs
sur la Loire
j'adore regarder la nature écouter la
silence pour moi c'est il y a pas il y a
pas de prix tour beaucoup de choses
comme ça et pour moi la vie ici c'est
c'est trop bien
c'est le chef de fil le capitaine
[Musique]
la pierre angulaire
intransigeant obstiné sur le terrain
papa poule dans la vie
[Musique]
toi tu es triche
ça c'est mon caractère aussi la deuxième
bonne heure je l'appelle en fait ça
devenait la première parce que la vraie
bonne heure c'est avec la famille avec
les enfants surtout l'infonce qu'ils ont
qui ont ça ça répète jamais et nous on a
7 bonheur participé avec eux
maudit la guerre il l'a connu petit en
Bosnie-Herzégovine au début des années
90 lors de l'éclatement de Lex
Yougoslavie
quand la guerre et la commencer j'avais
5 ans et toutes les images qui est j'ai
vécues ils ont ils ont toujours avec moi
et oui c'était
pas facile mais c'est l'enfance donc tu
penses pas à ça
cette force s’étrage il s'en est servi
chaque jour pour la partager au groupe
au TBB le plus grand club du volley
français dans sa quête de deux nouveaux
titres en 2023 tours
comme les temples tentent des volets
français et nous on a vraiment les
bonsoir à être là-bas sont-ils énergies
sont-ils cette exigeants de la
République
le volet c'est pas tout pour moi
bien sûr ces moments de travail que je
suis 100%
dedans et en plus tu es payé pour ça
c'est la bonne heure
mais j'ai essayé d'être un vrai père
pour vous mes filles pour voir un statut
un homme et une personne qui faut
respecter qui va te montrer en exemple
pour pour l'avenir
[Musique]
demain nous serons au côté d'un coach
ensoleillé le Brésilien Marcelo
francoviaque
[Musique]